one way or another thousands of people
are on the Move fleeing the escalating
crisis in Sudan Britain is trying to
evacuate people by air Sky News data and
forensics team have been tracking the
evacuation effort shortly before 7 A.M
local time a Lockheed Hercules left Raf
criteri in Cyprus it landed nearly four
hours later just before 10 in the
morning at what East Side in the air
base north of hartum we know the
aircraft was only on the tarmac for 28
minutes before taking off again south of
the air base has seen some of the most
intense fighting so getting through is
not easy for people trying to escape
we also have this footage released by
the British Ministry of Defense of
another Hercules in Cyprus in the early
hours it's being loaded up and personnel
with 40 Commando Brigade are preparing
to fly with it to hard tomb by sea
people are fleeing on passenger ships
making crossings from Port Sudan to
Jeddah in Saudi Arabia India's foreign
Ministry says 278 of its Nationals have
been evacuated on board the Indian Naval
warship the ins samadha the Indian
government says it plans to evacuate 3
000 of its Nationals from Sudan but most
people are fleeing by Road there are a
few routes out of hartum one is the big
and Long Drive East to the port of Sudan
now British Royal Marines have been
there on a reconnaissance mission
warships are also being sent Royal Naval
frigate HMS Lancaster is on its way and
RFA cardigan Bay is set to follow in due
course other ways out involved driving
North Overland on routes either side of
the Nile then crossing over into Egypt
south of Aber symbol at a number of
points on the border these are coaches
at the Argin Crossing lining up to get
out of Sudan and into Egypt all of these
Overland routes are fraught with danger
with widespread reports of vehicles
being stopped and people being robbed
getting out is dangerous but staying put
as the situation continues to
deteriorate increasingly perilous too